we live we live we live in Boston I know
what time it is I know who on the mic yo
who y'all got today man Jimmy Butler
versus Jason Tatum I'm gonna throw a
Boston Jersey on tonight Boston's gonna
win game one what's up big guy all right
I'm good man you're a good year man hey
I appreciate that man keep moving I'm
with the East now I'm all online like I
really think I could average 20 in the
NBA like he's going to be guarding me
he's too small the heat should come pick
me up because I I just don't see him
guard him am I stopping Tatum in the
paint yes he's not going through me
what's up gang man good luck tonight man
I was in Philly tonight I'm with you
tonight I was you know I was a ruby you
know how Reuben get I'm gonna need a
zero today too
I'm about to go get a Celtics Jersey
[Music]
with Tatum this week man 51 last week I
need another 40 ball today over here I
got potato more we're here y'all know
what it is it's about that time
[Applause]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
this is like the Chiefs maybe at the
beginning of the year
I'm laughing at the conference
yeah I really need trolling
that's what I like to see oh my God
oh my God start this
that's the three points foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
that's all
that's so late this is getting crazy
[Applause]
we gotta start talking about the Micah
Parsons curse how I lose one game and
I'm curious damn they stole game one
that's big it does I'm sixing myself
right now at the other night with a
tough loss I had to take the Celtics
Jersey off but it's all good man I'm
still repping Tatum bro still a bucket
and still one of the best of the leaves
I'm going to
in Miami take it to six I'm going to
Miami